the US government has long viewed the
Chinese company as an espionage threat
and has sought to keep Huawei from
playing a major role on the US
telecommunications infrastructure market
this new move is likely to prevent it
from supplying the equipment being used
to set up cutting-edge 5g networks
Donald Trump's decision has come at a
key moment in negotiations with the
Chinese government about future trade
relations between the countries China
because we've been treated very unfairly
for many many decades or actually a long
time and it should have been handled a
long time ago and it wasn't and we'll
handle it now I think it's going to be I
think it's going to turn out extremely
well we're in a very strong position we
are the piggy bank that everybody likes
to take advantage of or take from and we
can't let that happen anymore
the executive order makes it easier for
the US government to directly regulate
foreign telecoms which could
theoretically exploit backdoors and
systems to pose a threat to
communications and national security in
addition the u.s. is placed Huawei and
70 associated companies on a blacklist
firms on it have to be granted licenses
from the US Commerce Department to use
components made by US firms in their
technology the restrictions will come
into force in the next few days
let's pick up on this intriguing story
with Erin Tilton from our business
there's Erin who's going to hurt most
under this ban do you reckon on a
corporate level first of all Oh on a
corporate level I mean this is clearly
directed at Huawei even if the
government isn't saying that Huawei has
long been in the sights of the Trump
administration and even the US
government in general I mean the first
concerns about spying or brought up in
2012 so this is a long time coming now
the US isn't necessarily the biggest
market and destination for Huawei
technology but the distributed nature of
supply chains really means that if the
government has to approve all
transactions with Huawei this could
actually cause chaos throughout their
supply chain and they do have suppliers
who are within the United States and
that could of course have knock-on
effects throughout the rest of the world
as well but you also have to remember a
lot of rural companies internet service
providers are dependent upon Huawei
technology for district for creating the
next generation of mobile phone networks
because Huawei really produces the
cheapest reuters and switches out there
and if you know if they can't buy them
from Huawei that could mean we could see
a huge delay in the rollout of 5g
throughout the United States so what
would that mean for the consumer who's
waiting for the the next generation of
high-speed downloads does it mean
waiting a couple more years well it
could mean waiting a couple more years
it could also just you know not happen
at least not in in in the short term I
mean look we've we've talked about that
here in Germany a time and time again
Germany's had a huge problem when it
comes to rolling out the successive
generations of of mobile technology and
you know we could potentially see a
similar situation developing in the
United States but this is all an
economic emergency as Trump puts it
would this ban actually ensure safer
networks well that is kind of the big
question because really right now we
don't know what type of evidence the
United States has it's still under lock
and key supposedly based on certain
court documents through some Espeon
efforts of their own they were able to
determine that there's a more close
relationship between Chinese spies and
Huawei than the US government is
actually comfortable with but that's
only an infernal we haven't actually
seen the evidence yeah I mean I mean the
CEO of the company was a military
technology
just that sounds scary but at the same
time he's not going to want to put
backdoors in his equipment when he wants
his company to be successful globally
well you're you're right and he has said
as much he said it would be basically a
suicide for the company to do that
however Huawei has been accused of being
rather sloppy when it comes to their
supply chain management in general and
that is part of the concern of many many
telecoms here in Europe basically
they're saying there are so many kind of
parts that don't really work together
where they don't really know exactly how
they they're connected so that could
mean that could create vulnerabilities
in the network that hackers could
actually quite easily use and also
governmental hackers as well exactly
aren't tilton thank you very much for
coming in and thank you for the analysis
thank you